all right
um my more on my stance of the internals
okay so again remember the whole point
of the art is it's a practice it's a
it's a technology of
self and its whole orientation and its
whole agenda its aim is divine
communion end of story
because it was developed in a
culture that used a concentric
epistemology the manner in which you
gain Divine communion the manner in
which is
also
true and hence as
true it manifests in things like
fighting but fighting is not our
goal you can win at fights
outside of this truth and outside of the
means in which Divine
communion is made
possible so the whole point of the
internal aspects simplified in my system
say II and
koku a communing aspect and a separating
aspect the whole point of them is not to
make you
martially invincible
are you better off tactically having
them in your toolkit
yes than not having them yes will they
make you invincible
no what they do however
is the mechanisms by which the internals
are
manifested is the very me mechanisms by
which the obstruction to Divine
communion is
deconstructed that is the method in
which Ai and koku are
manifested is dependent upon the
deconstruction of the ego tripartite
mind the ego tripartite mind is the
final obstruction to Divine
communion toward this end
G is not a physical substance it is not
a magical
substance I would say it's a
metaphysical
concept describing the very
deconstruction of that ego tripartite
mind itself another metaphysical concept
when iI and CQ are used
tactically they
function just like any other physical
force would
function because Chi is not a substance
and she is not magical it does not do
something that other physical forces do
not
do the difference is how are they
manifested they are not manifested by
the physical processes by which other
physical forces are
manifested they are
manifested yes
physically but the means is
metaphysically and that's the difference
so this is where I don't agree with
other proponents I have put before you
such as uh Adam misner or DMO Mitchell
they're playing around with physical
substances uh I did a analysis of D
Mitchell's physicality and it's just
stupid
okay and anyone should see that it makes
no
sense but anybody who knows the cultural
history as I do do and as they
don't you would know that's inconsistent
with the historical
record that's not what they mean at
all so now question was raise uh how do
you do iy with the Joe as in Joe
doie as my first response is you do it
the same way you do iy all the time I
just a physical it's going to manifest
physically but it's going to be
generated
metaphysically and you could look at our
weapons work where we where my sword
will stick to the other person's sword
that's II that's the adhesion that's the
communion that's two inanimate
objects with very low friction
value able to stick
together Jo DOI should be even easier
because the friction value goes up on on
one of the elements the other person's
grab but we can make two swords to a Joe
and a sword two Joe stick together that
is adhesion that is
communion likewise we have video of
weapon on weapon where I project the
person through the weapon
it's the same it's not different I think
the question arises because we haven't
yet fully
accepted that while II and koku are
metaphysically
generated they manifest physically and
as they manifest physically they
function just like any other physical
Force they there's no magic to them okay
so you have to go back and understand
more
clearly U My overall position here
quickly
said um and the demonstrations that I
use to note those
differences um but here I'll do a little
kind of primer video to show you
something that people may have missed
okay on this topic
okay so um we'll do one of the iy drills
the the beginning iy drills well she'll
she'll has her arms crossed okay and she
lifts up her arms in the it cultivation
set number
one
okay and the way that I describe it is
the communion will arise when the Yang
value of this
movement is matched by my y value okay
so hence equal
Y what makes up her y value her
inertia that her inertia is she's
standing okay combined with her gravity
her materiality her Mass all of those
energy aspects
plus her movement going
up if I match that I can work at a 90°
fluctuating
angle and move her
forward okay so as uh just wait a
second as she goes up I match that and
then I get that adhesion right there
she'll feel it first before you see it
and that's what moves
her
um let's come really close and maybe get
on this
side so this adhesion is really just
another type of friction it's just
friction is what it is okay so the
friction is going to manifest in in the
slack of whatever's there so
um especially if you're not quite at the
perfect Yang value um so I will not do a
perfect yangong value and you will see
her skin will
move
um as she starts to do the exercise so
uh there is that skin right there do you
see so I'm moving her skin and then I
can just stay there until this pulls
she's leaning back on me but that's just
y value and I have to adapt to it so did
you feel yourself lean back okay so what
happens is is normally I want to talk
about that moment uh CU I'm still
teaching my people is that's a reaction
to the pool but the UK does not seek
control okay so what happened was um as
she starts to lift and I generate that
friction she felt herself go off balance
and she shifted her weight to the back
and you see that increases the Yong
value when she's doing that if I don't
stay up with it and I try to pull I'll
slip off okay so and and she'll fall
backwards okay but as she goes and I'll
have her do it again and I just keep
matching it and there's more pull on her
skin do you see and then eventually I
can pull her without slipping off got it
okay but you I don't want you to do that
stuff okay all right so you have to be
fine with losing control of what's going
on all
right some people will find this very
easy um and some people
won't the people that can ground vector
and take all of this young
aspect and Orient it towards the ground
they can do this at lighter
levels lighter levels of young
aspect the people that can't they
require higher levels of young aspect
grosser levels okay so uh I'm not going
to ground ground at all I'm just
standing here and uh as she goes really
slowly I'm never going to
get I'm never going to get that you'll
see that a
lot if she goes and I don't ground I
can't internalize and she goes up I can
generate higher levels of of uh Yang in
mine you see and uh she's tries to lift
up and I push down and now I can move
that thing forward do you see that um
but if I can internalize everything we
won't even use use this
movement okay there's enough young
aspect here and you could see the
the the you you got to I don't know talk
on how light My Touch is very light okay
it's very light but you can see that you
can get it to go okay uh does that make
sense okay it's crazy okay and that is
possible because I can internalize this
Yang aspect and get this third Point
into the equation of her her Yang aspect
my young aspect and then there's this
third Point through the internal through
grounding through me okay and that is
what I call uh alchemically treated Yong
this is this is just yon me shoving down
and trying to bring it forward but
alchemically treated
Yan uh is y that is bounced back off the
ground and then this this could be so
light so light and you could get it to
work um even in weird places okay now um
here there's no there's no there's not
really a ledge there anyways if you
think about it I'm not on the inside
okay but you can you can do it on places
where you you can't even really think
that you can do it so I'll
release don't lean back on
[Music]
me and you can get it to go so if you
pay attention you still will see the
friction I'll generate the friction
okay and you'll feel it okay what you're
going to feel is I'm using the up the up
of your young aspect do you see I'm not
here in front and it's magic Chi and I
and I pull this there is the up do you
feel it right there okay so you can make
it go back we're just making it go
forward so now I have it and then we go
forward with the up again it always
occurs at a 90° to her resistance her
young aspect okay so
[Music]
um let's stop there all right so I asked
my Desi here cuz you know I'm teaching
them to um tell me something that the uh
alchemically treated Yong can do that
just straight Yong can't do um and
Virginia noted something I did not say
which is very true but she feels it is
the straight blast young is really uh
doing the skin suit pulling where it's
just working on the joints it's not in
the center so for those who don't know
it's like I I just shov this down down
and then I can then I can move her um
you create that friction okay whereas
the other one the the alchemically
treated is always kind of locks
everything and make and she feels it
more from this part which is where I'm
trying to move her from I'm not trying
to move move her arms kind of thing okay
uh very very true and that's how you
seize the center so even even even when
I'm here and I do this then I'm already
in her Center at that point you're in
her Center uh which you cannot be when
you just kind of shove and generate
friction through this contestation and
then you move them you don't really have
their Center in that seizure sense okay
but the second thing that you can do is
you can work with extremely light levels
of Y okay which means tactically you
could Now
respond um through seizure much earlier
in the person's offense uh which is much
better to do okay that was my point uh
that you could work with lower y values
extremely low to the point where you are
now at weird edges that still function
in terms of equalize y meeting each
other still generates the communion the
friction making 2 one
um but in weird ways that the other
physical understandings just can't can't
manifest okay it's not I'm not I'm not
pulling her uh when I bring her forward
with her skin on the front I'm not doing
that that's not what's happening okay so
another tool in the
toolkit uh Chris asked the
question um wh why does it do that why
does it allow you to
generate uh
either a contact point an adhesion point
where there's no ledge or at extremely
low values of Y uh why does it let you
do that why does alchemically treated y
let you do that and to tell you the
honest truth I don't know I have no
idea um if I were to theorize I think it
has something to
do um in
part with just the
physiological aspect of having a
third um Force value in the equation I
think it radically Alters the equation
where you have her energy I have my
energy uh and now I have this third
point and I think when we think about
this uh only hers and mine at the the
contact point we we can't see all the
mathematical possibilities well we're
missing the huge portion that's also
involved in the equation I think that's
there I also think um that there's a
spiritual aspect to it that I can feel
more um what she's doing uh where is
this y value where is her y value I'm
more sensitive to that information and
so I can respond
accordingly uh as described uh much
earlier much lighter just because I'm
more aware of what she's actually doing
where where her body is where her Center
is I'm actually aware of of all of that
kind of stuff so part of it is I think
there's a third equation point in there
that goes from the feed all the way
through the tomen that is producing
other kind of force values into this
equation but too I think my awareness of
what her information is what's her y
value where is it located is much higher
in terms of its readability its
sensitivity and so I can do things at
more subtle levels not requiring gross
amplification of her young value to do
things okay here's one more thing the
alchemically treated y does
um and it's related to this increase in
Awareness it drops that ego tripartite
mind which is always issuing a kind of
blindness because it always filters
everything through through the
reification of the self where the other
is experienced as threat or no threat
and that leads to
blindness so as you are doing the energy
so as she has her her value there um as
I just not even moving her and I get
into that I can feel that whole threat
experience just drop in into my mind and
it does feel like a drop which is the
old expression it just feels like it's
going
down um and that's what you're playing
with in this exercise so to me this
could be the drill this could be the
drill like I already felt the Mind drop
which is also why I can do that with my
own young aspect I can do the standing
release drills and you'll feel the Mind
drop um and that does not happen with
trying to shove her down to generate
enough contestation that these two
things get stuck together in fact the
opposite happens okay
that's why big man iido is antithetical
to true iido true iido drops the ego
tripartite mind big man aido uh Rises it
okay all right so if she has now uh the
same drill okay and we start at the
bottom it's the same principle okay um
her skin is going to give a little more
uh friction than her Kee do you feel the
difference okay but not much not it's
not
much right so you can see that her skin
kind of moves a little just a little
with the weight of the weapon and then
there's no there's a little but it's
less and it is sliding over her skin so
there's less friction on her physical
there's more friction here do you see
with the weight of my hand because
there's more ition in these two surfaces
then over here but it doesn't change in
terms of what's it's doing okay um that
just means there's going to be less Yong
value at the contact point because
there's less friction friction is a Yong
value so but the principle is the same
so I have to um internalize all of this
let it all sink and as she lifts up I
just am kind of matching it
she doesn't lift up there'll be less yog
value which just means I have to match
it at a lower
value okay and nothing changes except
right what you can do and can't do does
that does that make sense of course you
you could do the same thing I shove it
way down here and then I pull it but
because I'm only and the arms you
eventually lose control of the center as
the SK skin suit adjusts okay um but you
can make them move that way okay and in
this sense you want her to move that way
it's a physical
property just like this is a physical
property it's just we understand that
physical
property
but I would say if you wanted to make
this purely physical
property it it would be the property of
friction that's what you're doing you're
generating friction between two objects
it's very it's not uncommon the way that
uh launch control on Modern cars uh
won't let you accelerate past the
friction that your tires can provide
that is pretty much what I'm doing here
okay if I if I go faster than her y
value I'll never stick if I'm underneath
it we're not going to go anywhere either
I have to match it perfectly okay the
way launch control is working in terms
of adhesion go in terms of CQ projection
okay so cooku projection is the
alchemically treated y that I admit out
is greater than the Y value at the
contact point then she gets separated
she gets displaced okay so um when I'm
when I'm here like this and I have equal
value so you can see her her her skin
her skin is being moved okay I'm holding
it right at the edge of her Center and
for me to project I just have to
increase the Y value
boom okay that's all doing there so if
she is holding the
Joe yeah okay you have to feel where
that Yong value is and then you have to
do higher yangong value so it's not
going to be going this way in that elbow
joint where her elbow joint can move do
you see you have to figure out where it
is I kind of went into that joint she
can feel that and then from in that
joint once I'm in that joint then I can
come around towards your Center and get
her to move okay so if I
go that way you see you're in the
joint and what the first thing I did was
I feel the Y the that her y value okay
there's that thing is locked now okay so
for example uh stay there I'm going to
change my angle and keep it there okay I
keep that same thing and I'm in her
Center and you can kind of just keep it
going and you'll move her with the I
key okay you increase it boom you'll get
the projection that's going there okay
it doesn't
change we're
here
pop keep it in there and you can move
her
around okay doesn't change nothing
changes okay
um keep that in mind and then we'll
we'll do something else let me hear your
questions as you're going um you should
have a lot of questions because this is
quite different from everything else
that I've seen out there every single
thing that I've seen out there I have
seen just as you have people adhere and
people project but the understanding in
my mind that the discourse on
understanding it
uh always veers from the historical
record and always brings a machine likee
materiality to the explanations which is
also veing from the historical record
and also de
prioritizes what is the ultimate
prioritization which is the dropping or
the deconstruction of the ego tripartite
mind which is the obstruction to Divine
communion